trump has also been as we now pushing
hydroxychloroquine as a treatment for
covet 19
since very early on now we have in you
know
probably episodes one through 18
frequently critiqued trump's response on
covet 19. he did
a very poor job in many many regards
but he was pushing hydroxychloroquine
early
there was not tremendous evidence
at that point now and you know it's it's
it's still
it's still a question and of course this
virus is evolving rapidly and so what
works now
may not work in the future but here we
have uh
zach if you want to show this
[Music]
an article written a few days ago on the
23rd of july
by a professor of epidemiology at the
yale school of public health who's an md
phd
who is making the point and he
references an article
that i can also pull up probably we
won't hear
in which he reviews uh the scientific
and medical literature
for uh hydroxychloroquine and finds it
to be highly efficacious
when delivered early in the course of
the disease which is what you would
expect
um not not late once um once you have uh
pretty high viral load and um are are
well into symptoms
but specifically he says that evidence
for the cocktail of hydroxychloroquine
zithramax and zinc is highly effective
now
is this will this turn out to be true i
don't i don't know for sure
of course uh he points to this actually
zach you want to put this up
um this is the peer-reviewed
article in the american general journal
of epidemiology published in the end of
may
actually this is fully two months ago
and
uh he it's basically a review article in
which he looks at the
you know scant but growing evidence
that this is actually an effective
treatment so
this has been one of the most obviously
politicized aspects of covet
right we've been talking since since the
beginning
about the about masks and i have a few
things to say about masks but
you know since march 24th when we first
began this uh we've been saying
actually ignore what the who says ignore
the us surgeon general
you should be wearing masks because that
is going to be effective and
and lo and behold um this virus is not
unlike every other respiratory virus out
there but masks are actually effective
in preventing transmission
um because trump has been pushing
hydroxychloroquine
the left media and therefore fully half
the country
have basically decided that there's no
chance it could be true
as as if medicine cares about your damn
politics
yeah it it's um it's absurd
and one wonders how so many people have
fallen
into this obviously wrong belief system
that the fact of trump saying something
makes it wrong right i mean in fact
um first of all
i think it is important that we step
back
um years it used to be
regularly said and implied
that trump was hit
right so you're not talking about
decades you're just talking about a
couple years i'm talking about a few
years at the point that
trump took office it was very common for
people on the left
to assert that this was the next version
of
this historical pattern i never hear
anybody tell me
oops we got that wrong but right
they just simply step into this next
phase of
everything trump is wrong and
um i must say that it does not do much
for my confidence and their opinion um
because obviously to the extent that
trump is
a cynical actor which i think he
frequently is to the extent that he's a
political actor which i think he always
is if i have one
central criticism of him and one reason
that i believe he absolutely
must be removed from office it's that he
politicizes
everything you know including the
hydroxychloroquine of course
thing but it doesn't make it false right
and if you
award him the weapon of if you say it
we will reject it then you have lost
yeah
right you have been gamed you've been
game you've been trolled you've been
gamed
you lose right so yeah a smart player
i mean you don't even have to be very
smart you just have to be a tiny bit
smart to understand
you cannot sign up for that rule right
if trump says it you don't know if it's
right or wrong i'd sign up for that
but if trump says it it's wrong is you
surrendering
it may be one of the biggest sources of
belonging for a lot of people in the
country right now
i think that is one of the appeals at
this point the where in the club we're
in the tribe
that knows that trump is evil and won't
all the problems be gone
if only we get rid of that and you know
of course all you have to do is look at
the messaging
of the protests and know that that that
isn't actually what will happen but a
lot of people are
so so seeking something to belong to
and the anti-trump crowd is is
one that in in many in many social
groups is a is a safe one
and actually it would be quite unsafe
you'd feel pretty bereft and alone if
you
said something to the contrary yeah and
in fact you know the funny thing about
um this podcast and the social world
that it is
a part of is that we attempt
to exist in the reality middle ground
where there's
very little cover right yeah to the
extent that one has to say
actually trump got this one right it's
like oh you're one of them you're a
closet trumper
right and to the extent you say no he
politicizes everything oh you have trump
derangement syndrome yeah
and so the point is you know it's a very
quick way to just
take almost everybody and eliminate them
from the ability to have a conversation
but it leaves a small number of people
who are willing to try to navigate that
um very much in your milieu and i
wouldn't want to be anywhere else but
there's a question about how safe it is
right because
the problem is both sides are demonizing
the middle for their own purposes
and um you know that's all well and good
as long as it stays on twitter i guess
but the problem is this is 2020 and a
lot of stuff appears to be spilling over
into the real
yeah it's not clear to me that what
happens on twitter stays on twitter
yeah no it clearly clearly doesn't yeah
so if aliens did actually land now yeah
and trump said oh my god aliens have
landed we must respond
then aliens didn't land we wouldn't
unify we would we would not actually
come together
you're right this is just like i mean
that stems exactly from what you just
said this is supposed to be the common
enemy this is global
this is big this is real this is not a
political entity it is a viral entity
and it has done the opposite of unifies
yeah it has done the exact opposite and
it's so it's tragic
[Music]
you